[Music]
i just discovered a way to build a
billion dollar startup entirely from
free open source software from the most
talented programmers in the world
actually everybody knows that already
like why pay an engineer when you can
just use their stuff for free on github
in today's video we're going to cheat
off the smart kid's homework and look at
some of the coolest open source
libraries that you've never heard of
tools that will make your apps faster
better looking and less expensive to run
you'll ask yourself what the [ __ ] how
have i not been using that already and
that brings us to library number one the
normally when you type a command into
the terminal and make a typo you just
say [ __ ] in your head and then retype
the command from scratch the [ __ ] makes
this process much more intuitive
allowing you to simply type [ __ ] into
the terminal then it will attempt to
reformat your command automatically to
be honest it's pretty [ __ ] useful
here's a problem that anybody who's ever
built a website is faced
it's too slow even if you work really
hard to create a tiny javascript bundle
the product manager will eventually tell
you to add a bunch of other chunks like
mixpanel intercom and google analytics
these third party scripts clog up the
main thread and will make your app slow
no matter what luckily there's an open
source library called partytown that can
run third party scripts from a webworker
javascript is single threaded but modern
browsers allow you to run background
jobs via web workers partytown will
offload any scripts that don't deal
directly with the ui into a webworker
and that means the only thing on the
main thread is your ui which leads to a
faster more responsive website another
problem that every app developer will
need to solve is user authentication
firebase is great but it's somewhat
feature limited auth0 is great but it's
expensive and that brings us to super
tokens which is an open source
authentication solution it provides sdks
for runtimes like node and python
allowing you to quickly self-host a
fully featured authentication system
with support for oauth providers
passwordless login but most importantly
it deals with session management and
security pretty cool but it's got
nothing on this next one hi mom is a
blazingly fast javascript library that
can say hi to your mom in record time
here's a pro tip if you're building an
open source library make sure that the
readme includes phrases like blazingly
fast bleeding edge holistic approach and
game changing because they make your
library better the same way putting
flame stickers on a car makes it go
faster next up we have a two for one
many businesses out there need to build
their own full tech search engine either
for internal data or to build a search
engine for their customers you could go
with elasticsearch but it's expensive
and complicated if you self-host there
are two very promising open source
alternatives one is melee search
implemented in rust and the other is
zinc implemented in go both provide a
fast simplified way to build your own
search engine now our next library trcp
tprc trpc is exceptionally cool but a
little harder to explain if you're
building an api today there are two main
approaches rest and graphql i won't go
into the differences right now although
i do have videos for that but there's
another less talked about approach
called rpc or remote procedure call and
basically it's just a url on a server
but unlike rest that corresponds to an
entity it corresponds to a function that
you want to run on the server this
approach actually makes a ton of sense
for many modern applications trpc allows
you to build entirely type safe apis
without the need for schemas or code
generation like you would with graphql
overall i think it has the potential to
fundamentally simplify the way we build
full stack web applications speaking of
simplification one company that has
simplified the modern database is
airtable the only problem is that you
have to pay a company to use it if only
there was an open source alternative
nokodi does exactly that it's an open
source air table that can be built on
top of your own mysql or postgres
database in other words it's an open
source no code database or smart
spreadsheet as a developer another piece
of software you may want to replace is
postman your http client an awesome open
source alternative is hopscotch which is
built with vue.js and typescript
entirely as a progressive web app not
only is it open source but you can go
use it in the browser right now at
hopscotch io and then install it as a
pwa on your desktop and now it runs in a
native window and allows you to interact
with your file system now if you've ever
coded in python then try javascript
later you might be shocked at how
difficult it is to work with
multi-dimensional arrays what is this in
python we have libraries like pandas
that can do all kinds of useful stuff to
an array or data frame not many people
realize that there's a library called
danfo.js that is inspired by pandas and
can do many of the things you know and
love like read a csv file and process
the data within it before it gets sent
to a machine learning library like
tensorflow that's pretty useful but the
hardest thing in front-end web
development is making your website look
good there's a million different tools
out there that can help you do that but
one i've been really loving recently for
react is manteen not only does it have a
bunch of well-crafted ui components like
this nice-looking timeline but it also
has a bunch of built-in hooks that
handle many of the annoying things that
you'll come across when building a web
app like debouncing an input or
paginating a collection of items on top
of that it has optional packages for a
notification system rich text editor and
a drop zone for file uploads it's so
awesome that we use it in one of the
demo apps in the full react course on
fireship io check it out if you want to
build a serious app with react now the
problem with all the libraries that
we've looked at so far is that they
require you to know how to write some
code if you have an idea for a full
stack application but want to skip the
whole learn to code part an open source
tool to check out is application it's a
tool that can automatically generate
both your frontend and backend code
based on relationships to data models in
a database that you can manage visually
the backend is built with other open
source tools like node nest js and
prisma while the front end is based on
react even if you do know how to code
this is a tool that can speed up your
workflow and that gives you 10 new open
source libraries to try out in your next
project hit the like button and
subscribe thanks for watching and i will
see you in the next one